well you say dingdong be a bear big
thing good except at me dad boots when
things go wrong just blink
Jamaica's a snapchat me that [ __ ] to
the dogs all day long
Stephanie that [ __ ] anyway welcome
every snap JP a [ __ ] is this a
successful intro did we do it right no
no we did it okay wait really
I don't know is this how are you a real
ax are alive is this my god
hello no we're keeping that intro I need
a [ __ ] welcome back in the Julian
podcast only that's cool another week of
being Jenna and Julian and doing a
podcast good intro and struggle bus what
is this pen doing here I brought this
for this podcast it's a metal finger pen
ah
anyway this week's podcast is brought to
you by club w ya get wine delivered
right to your door what happens is you
fill out a little survey little trivia
thing not a trivial little forum where I
get you via it tries to get your trivia
your your preference in wine so it's
like I like this I like that coffee I
like this one and they kind of just
gather information about what you like
and then they send you personalized wine
exactly what your palate what you know
needs and then after that you fill out
another quick very small couple
questions and then the next batch of
wine that you get sent is even better so
go to club w comm slash Jenna Julianne
and you get 50% off your first order the
links are in the description hopefully I
said that link right yeah Club W thank
you also I'm actually just going to read
this next sponsor because it's a movie
we're sponsored by a movie this week so
many pictures classic presents the new
hilarious comedy the bronze Wow the
bronze stars melissa rauch as
a foul-mouthed former gymnastics bronze
medalist he must fight for her local
celebrity status when a new young
athletes star rises in town also
starring Gary Cole Thomas Middleditch
sebastian stan cecilia strong from zion
alive oh well there we go i'm gardius
star and Haley Lee Richardson catch the
bronze in theaters everywhere March 18th
the bronze there's no place like there
that's really that's really fun Cecily
strong is really funny yeah we also have
a couple more sponsors we'll get to
those later but thank you to responsible
Thank You sponsors and thank you guys
for putting up with me reading sponsors
off of a piece of paper
it wasn't paper it was your phone this
is paper nice paper does that [ __ ] need a
[ __ ] if it's limitless paper in a
paperless world what a transition we are
gonna play a dunder mifflin trivia game
the office truth oh that was literally
from the office and it applied right now
okay first of all I'm wearing my glasses
which is very stressful for me I slept
in my contacts my accidents and I'm
wearing my glasses
Julian literally just five seconds ago
super glued them together guys I don't
know what to do to get you in Irvine ago
she has these broke-ass glasses that
always like the lens just pops off
you're not it's almost like oh please
that is not why they are broken no it is
not yes it is no it is not I win because
you didn't respond
the lens pops out at like it's like got
a mind of its own it comes out at the
worst time yeah like one time she was
she was about a catch peach and the lens
fell out and she like didn't know where
she was in peach
Fox with your depth perception I don't
I'm not saying you you know your your
visions at fault here it's more of you
need new glasses I don't know what to do
she won't get new glass if I may be like
what do I do
how do I get your prescription I don't
know what does that mean you don't know
you need to know this why do I need to
know I don't need to know you need to
know
it's a need-to-know basis and you need
to know it's on a piece of paper it was
in the front hall but I lost it
so that I could just walk in there and
be like hi any a new person alone sir
yeah then go do it listen I don't even
walk into [ __ ] lunch crafters or
whatever and be like hi
can I have a exam but I just had one and
that's annoying that I have to go make
another appointment and go and get
whatever get oh it's wait yeah oh it's
little whatever anyway
your thoughts on the fact that we're
gonna play that is what I'm saying that
I'm stressed out right now because I'm
wearing my glasses
Julian three seconds ago just super
glued them back together for me because
we tried hot glue hot glue works it
stays it keeps the lens in there for a
little while but then it falls apart
turn the paper super glue off my fingers
or a super glue will work better
although my brother apparently right now
is rockin super glue glasses together -
oh so it's like a it's in your blood
it's in my genes it's not our fault
because they're not broken there's
nothing wrong with them they just they
need a little help
no give up on him mm-hmm okay the only
difference is that mine were hot glued
and like you could visibly see all the
glue around the lens and our brother
goes to work every day with his glued
and at least I'm just around the house
so I mean it could be worse I could get
into an office every yeah I mean I would
literally drive me insane if I had to
wear glasses and they were broken to the
point where I glued them and had to glue
them and reglue them I would run I would
literally quit the podcast in the mid
podcast run you don't have the tangents
for glue the glasses or I do not I have
no patience for that see that's the
difference between you and me though I
have to have a lot of patience for my
boys mother different when they need
help another difference like I'm gonna
wreck at this game and you're not okay
here's the thing I have not really
watched a lot of the office as you guys
know Julian it's obsessive the office
but you know I don't like again it's a
funny show I just I don't know you
jealous you don't understand the concept
of watching shows that you've already
seen you don't get that yeah that's
something that's foreign to you for me
and a lot of people we watch shows that
we've already seen for comfort for like
for you know white noise when we're
working we just like to have it in our
lives because we're so engrained into
this world
for me it's like dunder mifflin the
office all the characters so it's like I
can just have that playing and it's just
like it's soothing to me no I understand
that
but what I don't understand someone asks
us to talk about it on the podcast like
studying habits and stuff at white noise
that the office is not white noise to me
I can't like read or attorney or
anything it's not white noise I can't
like listen to other people talk and
have a television show in the background
any complete silence I'm done it's not
really a following creating my phone and
you're talking to me I can't do both of
those at the same different folks
different strokes I mean honestly like
if I'm like on reddit or if I'm on the
internet somewhere on my computer and
I'm browsing whatever YouTube whatever
it is I can have the office playing in
one window but not be looking at it and
I'll be in five other windows do know
that that would make me insane that
would make me like implode and Xplode at
the same time well having your glasses
would make me insane and implode and
expose the same time fair enough fair
enough but yeah I don't like okay here's
my thing I understand rewatching TV
series because it's comforting mm-hmm
but I think what we're we don't see eye
to eye is like if you're flipping
through channels like Julian will always
turn all the offices on like let's turn
that on and I'm sitting down like we've
already seen this let's watch something
we haven't seen right now hmm
like I get going back and re watching it
sometimes but like it's your go to like
if we're sitting down and eating
something you're like let's watch old
seasons of the office and I'm like
survivors on like we can watch something
new that's happening right now no but I
get that way with I think it's also just
like a sitcom anything like her watching
Seinfeld while we eat then like the
survivor because like it's more of like
a relaxing I can trust this show to eat
in front of whereas like to survive I
don't want to be invested to pay
attention to the best you can be leaking
at your food while you listen and get
the same that's a bad example but what
I'm trying to say is like when we're
we're sitting and we're watching TV
we're having TV time you'll flip on like
an old season of Friday Night Lights
which is great and wonderful behavior
we've already seen that we're sitting
here watching TV let's watch something
we haven't seen why why just you love a
show so much yet you can't watch it more
than once how not you can but I don't
know maybe maybe those of you that are
listening like hear what I'm trying to
say and maybe those things I'm saying
here we're not right or wrong it's just
different different habits and different
news not that I don't like rewatching
shows but like when you have your like
nighttime TV time I'm like Laki do we
have to watch something we've already
watched
sometimes you turn it on and Saracens
looking damn good and you're like you
know what I don't see what happens even
though I kind of already know it's just
exhausting that's how I feel about the
office like Julien seen every episode
ever
I've seen enough episodes I don't need
to watch every season mm yeah um I'm
like why do we have to watch this right
now
agree to disagree give me the finger be
a pen I wanna make a quick correction
it's Club w.com slash Jenna and Julie
house in hand in there I'm not sure what
happened with that one but sorry about
that if you click the link in the
description I'll take you right there
though not an Indian yeah thanks I was
really asking your forgiveness we start
a sentence innuendos oh yeah so we're
playing the office trivia so it's it's
an app we downloaded which you already
know I'm going to fail miserably at I
don't know anything yeah um so this will
probably be like celebrity trivia but
for Jenna oh is that what we're doing
what this is well no because we're both
going to play but we are now in dunder
mifflin we are now in Scranton PA so
there's a bunch of different levels to
this game level one is Jim and Pam [ __ ]
at all a game objectives we should read
this welcome to office trivia quiz test
your knowledge of each knowledge of each
character and find out where you stack
up past level one you become a Salesman
work your way through the levels and
advance to be the CEO of sabra all right
Sabra like the hummus company yeah but
it's an office thing
or saber saber saber dunder-mifflin is
upon us all I knew get literally amount
of them how to play beginner level one
answer three questions correct in a row
and claim your reward move on a level to
repeat this through all the characters
and complete the game miss a question
try again until you aced the quiz so
basically you need three answers in a
row correct to pass the level got it
alright so how having it is you you want
to just like answer the mind you asking
me how we're gonna do this level one Jim
and Pam there's no there's no music or
they probably couldn't license it why
would there be music oh okay what part
does Jim play in Michaels movie what are
the choices Goldfinger golden face spy
policeman am I supposed to guess yeah
are you playing golden face what do you
think I don't understand don't want me
to guess cuz I don't know anything and
you know that Alright you play I'll play
this level okay you play well why don't
you just chill out it's the office
golden face correct thank you what does
Pam injure play ankle come on you didn't
even read it no which is good you're
playing volleyball the company picnic no
one knows what's happening guys you've
you've done the choice food is gentle
even of us who does Jim leave in the
bathroom at a gas station because of an
emergency with Cece why are you looking
at me I thought you playing this Rambo
Michael pass wait should we just go for
a record now what is the name of Jim and
Pam second child who James no snaps
fingers Michael no I felt Michael
Cecilia
no it's it's Phillip we got it right
again good job I'm not doing anything
Oh how do you want to do this then no
you said you were playing this level so
at least read the choices the other one
which other job Jim held at the office
was a warehouse supervisor receptionist
accountant co-manager
mmm-hmm-hmm co-manager yes surely
correct answers 5 incorrect 0 total
score 28 all right quit now jenna is
going to level 2 accounting man I just
can't [ __ ] wait here we go
alright you can't if I'm playing you
can't need to be the answer what season
does Angela get pregnant
alright that's actually tough boom
season 6 she got wrong I see the Nathan
what does Kevin screw on his IQ test oh
these are tough okay I'm gonna say under
90 my choices are over 176 120 or under
90 if you answer 76 under 90 is also
correct right I'm saying under 90 over a
hundred damn where does Kevin Plank Road
sign parking lot bathroom or Dwight's
desk I'm gonna say Dwight steps oh yes I
got one
what does Kevin think justified means
how text is placed on a page Angela a PI
are justifiable homicide I'm gonna say
justifiable homicide nice two in a row
you need one more to pass I don't even
need to see the show
what does Oscar receive as compensation
for discrimination at the office are you
going to read the choices okay aha a
house a big flat-screen TV a computer
three months paid vacation to Europe
three months paid vacation to Europe to
the past see why would I waste my time
watching the show did you get joy and
it's an amazing show stop [ __ ] on it
all right level three Creed isn't gonna
be good it's gonna be [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] all right
who sets up Creed Creed's fake blog Ryan
Michael Jim or computer guy right got it
it was Creed's career in the 1960s rock
musician stockbroker rock climber dr.
Rocky
Wow good work where does Crete live his
child's house his aunt's house his mom's
house he is homeless he's homeless
how many toes this Creed have on his
right foot six four three five core
think it's for you no you know what's at
it
whoo [ __ ] is Creed what are you doing
what is that what is the subject of
Creed speech and Andy small business
conference office management et starwars
Loch Ness monster Loch Ness night I got
five correct and zero incorrect are you
having fun yet no I'm not on it all open
no it's not fun it's not fun all right
so do you want to play you wanna play
trivia or something trivy
yeah that's the YouTuber one is that it
it's um Retin rhett and Link see you
want to do that you guys probably know I
want to do one round yeah with it no I'm
gonna finish this game we're going to
end it right I'm gonna go I'm going to
fast forward to Season nine and just
destroy the competition okay fine god I
know you guys are proud of this all
right who brings lice to the office
Meredith Pam Phyllis Angela Pam why did
the employees pair into couples to bring
snacks to get their work done to carpool
to get a discount to get a discount at
the nail salon who does Angela asked to
spy on her husband to see if she is
cheating or he is cheating on her
Meredith Kevin Jim Oscar was not
Meredith
it's not Kevin Jim Hoss Oh Oscar though
yeah they go together yoga
got that who does the senator invite to
their son's first birthday party Oscar I
got it right
who are the new employees Clark and Andy
Clark and Pete
it's Clark and Pete or Clark and plop
they clump plop word five and I'll
destroy the competition
RIPD the competition all right well
those cool I guess huh no no it wasn't I
[ __ ] hate you right now
I hope you're happy I'm like I hope
everyone else is happy that we're
letting Julian do this is the worst
podcast ever in my life and it's comedy
no this is my hell all right all right
okay I'm sorry I had I had to do that
all right it did something for me I
appreciate you let me get did you have
to I love you anymore
Trippi walking what Vee if you don't eat
Jimmy I'm gonna play that song again
play I dare you scoff did you say scoffs
kah Parks and Rec joke can we even post
this podcast if you play keep playing
that song okay let's play to it oh my
god you're a piece of work
yeah all right I want to play Dominic
like d-trix yes so this is basically
trivia of youtubers right yeah well
we'll try our best to make sure we play
some trivia and cover our bases in case
nobody knows any of the office or yeah
other youtubers we don't know I don't
know your life I don't know your deal
okay all right so d-trix
that's why are you ready two-timed yeah
these are tent
what do prisoners use to contact each
other in prison
this is dietrichson's jail phones cell
phones cells it's up cells gonna be soap
jail phones soap so Julian says that's
wrong
[ __ ] on why is that a d-trix question I
don't know that's weird
all right let's try continue all right
and draw my life video my dad had a
small car hat house or scar [ __ ] I don't
know house house house he was car it's
not house this is so frustrating it
doesn't give you the right in yeah that
is frustrating okay you guys we're just
never gonna know d-trix we love you I'm
sorry we don't know those we're failing
no Dietrich's is our friend all right my
favorite way to workout is CrossFit
running dancing and singing dancing
dancing we're gonna go with the dentists
got it oh we gotta keep going
what is my favorite zoo animal lion
tiger monkey or elephant
monkey monkey I'd say tiger okay no I
thought I'd say Rob it's not a tiger
y'all damn I just got an ad yeah that's
one [ __ ] that [ __ ] but which NBA team
did I use to dance for Golden State
Warriors sarcomere Sacramento Kings LA
Lakers it's one of the top two it's
Northern California I would say
Sacramento Kings I would say Sacramento
Kings yes yeah okay
correct okay what was a first seats for
Gabriel and now it a dancer 300 a dancer
which one did he just come out when our
friends probably we gotta go friends
running out of time what game do we play
in the Taco Bell challenge video hey
that's taco pong we were in that one
taco pong that was that that was us nice
pong my favorite kind of bags are to me
James for Louie Vuitton or Gucci
JanSport or two I would listen to me
it's JanSport vivid it's to me at a time
yeah totally Luther on d-trix I just
remove on Earth Eve yeah let's do
different one how many watermelons did
we have two E in ten minutes fifty
twenty ten
ten to ten it was ten [ __ ] watermelon
yeah he doesn't press of [ __ ] with those
food challenges and they're all legit by
the way what color shirt am i wearing in
my 20 faces video what black no you
wrong you wrong you rock Julian you fail
I went to high school in which city
check remember no Roosevelt Roosevelt
rallies now it sounds like something new
it
what celebrity is my ass is actually my
uncle Keenan tolerate any Murphy Tim
Meadows it's due tonight no idea I would
say ten minutes it's not a real [ __ ]
it is a Tim Meadows hmm I was a
background dancer in a music video for
which Ben baller boy
Bob one is all yours no follow boy
all-time low panic at the disco or My
Chemical Romance I can't fall out boy or
a [ __ ] dead great job Jenna you did
this all right different youtuber now
who do you want to play don't do that
with that pen you nasty you nasty
whoa what we just said at the same time
you want to play capital cities cuz I do
it's capital cities capital cities I
don't know what this is over Rua is the
capital I've probably [ __ ] cook
islands islands definitely it is what is
singles capital city Harris the car
Poland or Georgetown and Stephanie Dakar
Georgetown no it's not George happens to
car
I think it's Georgetown why would you
pick Georgetown
it did take Georgetown we're not doing
capital cities we have a youtuber trivia
app on our hands why would we win one is
the capital of Puerto Rico yeah Jenna
what is bangladesh's capital city um
Dhaka it is Dhaka
nuke is the capital ah ha ha all right
Julian you know what guys times like
this when you're hanging out with
someone playing an app and you're
they're not doing you want so you did
you know I got it uh you just got to go
to the other room and
SMTV and there's no better TV to watch
them vice land which is a brand new
channel from vice which um which houses
some of the most amazing news shows
release for those who don't know they
make documentaries they make series they
make shows but they're all very
incredible vice land is their new
channel they launch launched last last
week I think right the February 29th it
launched so the shows are already
happening I watched one of the shows is
called balls-deep with this guy named
Thomas Morton he goes around literally
all around the world and experiences
different ways of living and it's so
amazingly interesting it's like the
reason you guys watch youtubers and
bloggers you just want to see how other
people live and they do such an amazing
job
so check out Vice land which is vices
new channel with all these amazing shows
there's a really really cool topics that
they cover so check that out guys also
make sure you get your wine get your
wine delivered go to club w comm slash
Jenna and Julianne mmm that's club w.com
slash Jenna and Julianne and get your
wand delivered right to your house
customized for your palate no not him
you you're a palate okay it's going to
be one that you like and even though
having your method of picking out wine
being which bottle looks good even
though that's flawed they still have
good looking bottles Julie right god
they really did the bottles look cool
and the wine tastes great we've we've
actually brought it out here and drank
it on the podcast you guys have seen it
and also we've seen you guys tweet at us
that you've ordered Club W and like it
because that's so cool to us that you
guys try out our sponsors it really
means a lot that you support the
sponsors that support the podcast
because it keeps the podcast free for
you guys thank you to club w thank you
device make sure you check out both of
those things all of the links all of the
info in the description back to trivy
know well you get you can pick whatever
you want to play but do you not want to
do youtubers know you can't even do it
everyone let's do uh I'm just pulling
apart my hot glue that came from my
glasses because [ __ ] my glasses my
glasses they fell apart
and yeah that's telling dog chew Donna
that's not how my hermit chewed my first
mystery guitar man I don't know enough
all right
hmm I know I don't know now Shane Dawson
Xue Shan Shan Shan Shan trivy shame
trivia Rigo my most popular YouTube
video on shanedawsontv is Lady gaga
tried to kill me
fred is dead Miley Cyrus weekend is not
parody Miley Cyrus wrecking ball parody
I would say wrecking ball parody yes got
it read it what was the first food item
in the nasty fast food challenge Taco
Bell burger patty McDonald's melty
delicious Dairy Queen's combo soup EW
King taco smoothie yeah I was a king
taco smoothie do it whatever young God
that you have no time yeah it's hard who
played Lady Gaga
and Lady gaga try to kill me Liz bug
Kristen Finley me Brittani Louise Taylor
don't say Liz bug I don't know
no Brittani Louise Taylor do Britney
yeah yes that's right initially ryx I
can't stop blank everything cleaning
kicking licking hitting and licking
licking licking yeah yeah that's right
and my blindfolded taste test challenge
with Joey Graceffa what like first baby
food butter mango dog food butter do it
yeah that's right which one is not my
favorite wait which one is not one of my
YouTube channel Shane Shane Dawson TV
shanedawsontv shanedawsontv to awesome
TV yes correct
in my Sunday video who did Sheneneh
collab with Megan Nicole Andrea Russett
mamrie Hart Rebecca Black Rebecca Black
write her no that makes sense though
that's right it is is rebecca black you
just got a check point yeah we can't
Shane okay here we go
Trisha Paytas got me a t-shirt and
sunglasses from which reality show a big
brother The Voice Dance Moms Amazing
Race
The Voice right No
Big Brother Big Brother he loves me
brother
yeah [ __ ] in my truth or day challenge
with Joey Graceffa what was the first
dare maybe that was truth or dare drink
your own pee e 2 pieces dog food sit on
the lap of the person next to you go
outside go outside scream ahh that's
funny though
imagine that that's like that's funny oh
my god boy oh my god
what ok who did the smoothie challenge
with me Tyler Oakley Tiger sefa mamrie
Hart
sorry Hartman Tyler Oakley maybe I don't
choice Oh Jerry
Siddalee are Joey yeah kick Joey oh no
it's not Joey sock Joe's gonna pick Joey
it was wrong hey you know the first I
hate my selfies shirt film is based on
which chapter of my book internet-famous
my birthday suit just a pretty face or
prom prom ah
I prom yeah let such what is my middle
name
Lee Kyle Don James [ __ ] [ __ ] it's Lee
Shane Lee Dawson oh I think you're right
it is actually good work
in my fifty shades of gray parody where
did mrs. gray and I make out I didn't
want Lee in toilet hallway patient room
waiting room let's do a patient room
patient room damn it's not patient room
have we not seen that no know what high
school did I go to Lakewood High School
Lake High School Long Beach High School
Redondo Beach High School miss a
Lakewood High School um is that a place
no yeah we played them in high school I
don't liquid all right what did the
first candy what was the first candy I
tried an extreme sour candy challenge
sour patch kids sour skittles sour M&M
sour swedish fish
sour M&Ms sour skittles sour skittles
okay that's how her skin looks this is
hard this is the hardest [ __ ] hearts
[ __ ] Shane Shane Shane okay which one of
my music videos that I recently do a
reaction video to super love this life
[ __ ] up the vacation zone what
um super love this song yeah China stock
you was the first question my sexual
would you rather video have cookies or
french fries no internet or cell phone
have a dragon via dragon he shat on her
peed on I don't know we didn't know cell
phone chimes arms up see but reading the
answers takes time out loud so that's
probably why I feels like there's more
time
which of these Taylor Swift songs did I
not make a period of I knew your trouble
blank space shake it off 22 I would say
I knew you were trouble did you make a
parody of that I think shake it off did
he make a pair yeah so 22 22 wait doli
Julie you got it wrong you got must it
most it yeah ouch
okay yeah you hit your own okay that's
where your pen goes had it with you and
you pen in your office I'm sorry do you
want me to go get it Julianne's did it
alright I'm tired I'm sorry I didn't do
it play it no I don't like when you've
encouraged me it took I know it scares
me you know
do it do it though why don't you
enlighten all of us why don't you call
this
yeah bit twist it favorite part of the
office favorite part yeah come on that's
a weird question
or something that you love something
much you love an office PIPA Pete ha
that's a great that's a great moment
when Dwight says house how's your
daughter doing pp is her name and she
goes no PIPA her name is ceci so he's
just playing along with the joke mmm
doesn't translate when you talk about
the office to someone who doesn't watch
it right it was exactly why I never want
to watch it because you you make jokes
like that all the time that I'm like mmm
sounds hysterical sometimes I'll just
start a sentence and I don't even know
where I'm going I just hope I can figure
it out along the way
I'm office but isn't office club like to
see this is like I'm trapped in it I
could never get out of it you live you
live you married me so I mean this is
where you married into okay does anyone
out there have a significant other
that's obsessed with something that you
are not obsessed with and you do they
make you have to endure it all the time
because if you do the person who makes
you endure it is the real MVP are they
aren't they are the person that makes
you endure is the real MVP Eddie he'll
[ __ ] yeah God like I'm trying to think
of something that I subject you to but
you get in Project Runway you get into
that stuff yeah cuz it's good you get
into Top Model
you will give office a chance man that
is not I give Project Runway a chance
I give America's Next Top Model a chance
and and they're great you don't give the
office a chance it's better than both of
us I know it's a good show but no you
don't cuz you never watched it don't
take me free pen I like when you said
you done much you got my foot it you
like you mess no I know I missed it you
done missed it thunder miss yeah like
them I like that you done missed it it
doesn't missed it that should have been
in the office yeah see if I wrote that
child that that would be everybody Billy
didn't you done minute um guys let us
know in the comments if you have similar
situations because we want to laugh at
you guys like you're laughing at us
about how I love office and she hates it
it's not hey also let us know how how
much you can't understand why she hates
such a great show in the comments and
hit the thumbs up on if you like me and
hit the thumbs down button if you like
jump
I've done it a thumbs down button I'm
joking that's the second time I've
encouraged people to hit the thumbs down
button movies just go ham uh I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm not sorry mood why don't
you ask me a trivia question about the
office rude yeah who does the chili
cook-off it's a Stanley no that's Kevin
that's your favorite moment yes
[ __ ] it's Kevin I was in town no what
was I oh yeah who's Robert California
hit on when she's drunk Robert
California is a girl know when she when
the girl is drunk who does he hit on
when she is drunk Pam no yeah it's
always Pam it's not Pam it's Erin who's
Erin Aaron's new Pam Oh Pam 2.0 mmm no
she's just a new recession headed girl
yeah that's her all right ask me now who
does Erin meet at the office panel in
that theater hmm Dwight her parents it's
Jay
no she meets her parents it's so funny
cuz she's adopted she never met her
parents and so some of the audience is
like when you talked about no they're at
the mic in South there when you talked
about your mom that was really sweet and
she's like huh Thanks and she's like
have you ever it may if you ever met
your mom would you be mad at her cuz I'd
be really mad at her and she was like no
I think I'd probably meet her and she's
like honey crying it's like a really
weird thing but it's yes interesting
storyline ask me another question okay
what is Jim's second job uh we had that
on the truth no no it's a different
question oh okay
um not in the office his whole entire
single okay he buys paper nope no it's
sports marketing in Philadelphia I'm
sure he doesn't just buy paper yes so
then he could double his money selling
paper and by the amount of the amount of
incorrectness in that statement is
making me twitch
what does Jim break the window in the
office with Oh nope lacrosse ball I was
close though actually it's a lacrosse
stick with a snowball in lacrosse net
all right well
we don't have to keep doing this no I
like it yeah okay who does Pam date Jim
do you need me for this sir who does Pam
date Jim who is the boss Michael Scott
yes yeah good one where do they work
Dunder Mifflin where do they honey stop
asking yourself easy questions to make
you sound self sound smart games Matt's
office quote mm-hmm
hmm who is Dwight Dwight that's good
come on I know [ __ ] it's not bad maybe
that it's it's not horrible
who is pam pam is Pam I'm doing good
didn't you know it I know everything
there is to know about the show why
would I sit down and watch it when I
already know everything you're not
you're not you don't know everything
he's saying words oh my god chili
cook-off chili cook-off well thank you
guys for hanging out with us for another
week of the Jenna and Julian podcast
sorry it was so [ __ ] I'm not sorry
because it was kind of fun well Julian
we let you indulge in your office you
know what I want to thank you for that I
want to send a special thanks out to my
girlfriend Jenna and my co podcaster for
letting me have this podcast to be a
[ __ ] little office fan well you feel
like you sneaked in your office jokes
I'm a dunder mifflin every podcast so
you know we let you have your yeah and
you know what this this helped me purge
that office energy so that right in the
next pod house I'm only gonna do five
quotes instead of saying that vine
nothing you done missed it uh thank you
guys again uh you know hit in the
comments with um your experiences with
things like this also uh let us know who
you guys want on the podcast just as
ideas if you have ideas for guest
youtubers stuff like that let us know in
the comments we try to make that happen
because we hear not guess in a while we
also have not had a guest on a green
screen
interesting and all the sponsor
information is in the description thank
you to our sponsors please go check them
out it makes the pot gets free for you
guys and we'll see you guys next week
play your little song to play us out
what does that mean to play us out play
us out live [ __ ] you
not even the good version yeah because
they probably can use it it's not the
real version because they can't use the
real version it's just some janky app
this is not how whiny dancing oh my god
are you happy my guys had it have it
I've had it with you and this [ __ ] I'm
out of here
[ __ ] bye how did we got I love you